what happens when you mix So I Married
an Ax Murderer with Scarlet Witch you
get HBO's latest crime drama Love and
Death which tells the crazy true story
of Candy Montgomery her affair with
neighbor Al Gore no not that one and the
murder of his wife Betty in this video
we'll be going over the show's ending
connections to the true story and of
course
I was perfectly shaped penis I've ever
seen okay maybe not that while the
murder of Betty Gore doesn't take place
until halfway through the series The
Show's first three episodes Focus
instead on Candy's affair with Alan with
episode 1 of being the initial
attraction to the affair itself and
three the breakup all of which culminate
in Betty's eventual murder in episode 4.
the show could have easily started with
the murder but instead spends three
hours building up the characters
providing much needed context into how
and why they do the things they do both
candy and Allen are unsatisfied in their
marriage candy feels ignored by her
husband he doesn't take an interest in
the things she likes like her writing
club and even turns down her sexual
advances this all culminates in candy
feeling there's more to life than what's
been given to her I do want more
and I'm not going to apologize for it
Allen on the other hand has a wife
suffering from depression anxiety and is
stuck in a relationship where sex is
treated like a chore so when candy comes
up to him and is like would you be
interested in having an affair what it
takes some coaxing but he's eventually
in even creating a list of Rules by
which he and candy are to follow to
ensure their Affair remains secretive
and feelings aren't hurt but as feelings
do develop between the two and Alan
tries to salvage his marriage with Betty
their Affair Peters out leading to that
fateful June when Betty confronts candy
about the affair it's implied that Betty
was able to uncover this affair by
noticing the glances the two share their
private conversations and Alan always
knowing what's going on in the
Montgomery household so Betty just
outright asks candy if there was an
affair and she doesn't deny it not only
does Betty deal with his bombshell but
it's set against the backdrop of her
depression the possibility of her being
pregnant and the anxiety caused when her
husband's away on business so all this
culminates in her threatening candy with
her husband's ax and before we get any
further if you like these kinds of
videos be sure to like And subscribe
every little bit helps the channel out
only one person knows what actually
transpired on that fateful day at least
one person that's still living but the
show portrays this scenario as outlined
by the defense candy defending herself
from Betty who had snapped violently
Cuts Betty with an ax as staggering 41
times now the question then becomes was
this in self-defense when the court case
transpired in 1980 it garnered
significant media attention due to
various factors one the violent nature
of the crime two the defense's strategy
of claiming self-defense and three that
such a violent crime was committed by
what attorney Don Crowder calls a mousy
housewife now the defense does a pretty
good job at arguing the murder was not
premeditated Gandhi wouldn't have known
this ax was in the garage she never set
foot in it and will also learn candy had
no motivation to kill Betty her
relationship with Alan just petered out
and the two never had any Grand plans to
run away with each other so it's not
like candy wanted to kill Betty so he
could get Alan back but the hardest fact
the defense must overcome is the
particularly violent nature of the crime
how do you explain someone being cut
with an ax 41 times self-defense doesn't
account for 40 whacks we need facing
this is where Dr Faison comes in in
episode 5 he performs hypnosis on Candy
to get at the core of what caused candy
to act out so aggressively and this
stems from a traumatic experience she
had as a child instead of her mother
comforting her through this traumatic
event she was shushed and told to be
quiet so when Betty attacked and went
just like her mother did it triggered
what the doctor called a dissociative
reaction in which a portion of her
personality was split off from her
Consciousness to highlight the effect
her mother had on her we get a nightmare
sequence in which her mother visits her
and hands her a knife saying you have to
defend yourself so if you're to believe
the defense Betty's attack triggered in
candy a disassociative event in which
she essentially blanked out and took all
that built up rage on Betty hence the
brutal nature of the crime her going
about her day just like normal after the
murder was her way of coping with what
she had just done to go about everything
like it never happened the show also
depicts defense lawyer Don Crowder as
this win at all Stakes type of guy who
even gets former friends of Betty and
even the pastor to talk about her
there's a particular line from Dawn's
wife that I found interesting
considering Dawn would take his own life
over a decade later this whole thing is
gonna eat at you
the jury composed of nine women and
three men took less than four hours to
find Candy Montgomery not guilty as
Candy's husband explains even though she
was found not guilty she wasn't found
innocent as long as they're in Texas
things will never go back to normal
hence why they pack up and move to
Georgia but before candy leaves she says
goodbye to Alan a man who believes
himself responsible for this whole
debacle that he's dead
because I cheated on her if I'm not
mistaken we never see him shed a tear
over Betty's death in fact he doesn't
seem to invest it in the outcome of the
trial at all well whatever happens I'm
sure it'll all be for the best even
Betty's father says and he's dead why
doesn't that bother you
we weren't getting along too well candy
passes the Como Motel one of the
locations of her affair with Alan as the
family starts a new life we do get an
update on some of the characters most of
whom have split from their Partners but
perhaps the largest impact this story
has was on self-defense law itself with
the Montgomery case often cited as a
successful use of a self-defense claim
but now I hand it over to you what
verdict would you have chosen if you
were on that jury I want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below thanks
for watching please make sure to like
And subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
wow that is so sweet
thank you